It's difficult for you...
Isn't it Nash?
there's so much unfinished business
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my flash season 6 episode 12
video they just introduced sue dibny on
the TV show and we got our new version a
mere master finally realizing their
powers so we'll break it all down if
you're new to the channel we're doing a
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your favorite moment from the episode on
the video we'll just do top 10 and
easter eggs careful for spoilers if you
have not seen the episode yet we'll
start with number 10
iris inside the mirror dimension meeting
the new mirror master they kind of
explained the mechanics of what's going
on how long she's been trapped in there
when she got trapped in there and then
she sort of discovers her powers through
the course of the episode but the whole
idea is is that when the particle
accelerator blew up at the beginning of
season 1 that's when she was kicked
through the mirror because it was bathed
in dark matter but also we find by the
end of the episode her body was also
changed so now she has meta mirror
master powers which is a very new 52
change if you weren't a big flash comic
book reader they do give a shout out to
the first version of mirror master Sam
Scudder because they did him way back in
season 3 they even do a big callback to
the episode where the flash and Jesse
quick fought him and Barry got trapped
in the mirror by mirror master so the
whole idea in the flash comics is that
the original version of mirror master
was Sam Scudder so they did him first on
the flash TV show
Evan McCulloch was the second version of
mirror master who took up the mantle
after Sam Scudder in the comics now
they're kind of doing that on the TV
show but originally in the comics Evan
McCulloch was a tech base Vil and he
used the mirror gun to give him his
powers and open up portals to the mirror
dimension they just changed that during
the new 52 to make all the Rogues
Mehta's instead of using tech but then
during flash rebirth they sort of reset
all that so most of the flash rogues are
tech based villains but every once in a
while there's a meta based one and the
flash TV show is just doing the new 52
version of that you can kind of see her
go full-blown crazy through the episode
so I think this is them just providing a
really rich backstory for her in a
tragic villain arc so that when she does
go full comic book mirror master and
becomes a big villain during the season
it makes a little more sense how she got
to that point but number 9 the Lex
Luthor newspaper crisis on Infinite
Earths Easter eggs and earth prime stuff
so you just see a Lex Luthor Supergirl
and all the combined Earth's stuff going
on in the background on other TV shows
be natural that the people on the flash
would be talking about stuff that's
happening in other parts of the world on
the other TV shows really good example
is Cisco now in the earth prime reality
the new version the timeline being a
really big Superman fan boy of course he
would grow up being a Superman fan boy
if he grew up on an earth that had a
Superman Barry also complains about
feeling a little sore after last week's
terrible episode he's probably sore one
because the episode was terrible but
also because it's set up for the
storyline the death of the Speed Force
that they're going to culminate in the
Wally West's return which will be
episode 14 this year so all the Barry
weird Speed Force power glitches and all
that stuff that'll all be explained
during the Wally West episode but it's
all leading up to something but number 8
fake iris is trying to steal the
mirror gun for some reason so remember
she's a mere copy of iris from another
dimension so we're not really sure if
she's evil what her goal is they're just
sort of setting up the idea that she's
trying to pull a fast one on Barry for
some strange reason there's a big
callback to the stark Ives where they
keep all their gear from previous
adventures and seasons that will
eventually form the bulk of the flash
Museum so in the future timelines when
we would go visit the flash Museum like
last season all that gear all that stuff
is stored in this warehouse like they
have reverse flashes Timeship stored in
here all kinds of other really cool
Easter eggs every once in a while so
anytime they go back there it's really
fun to try and look in the background
and try to find other Easter eggs if you
can
number seven meet soo did nice oh
they finally introduced the character on
the show they've been talking about her
since the end of season five but they
set her up in this very James Bond Jason
Bourne type of way secret agent movie
where she saves Ralph from this big
explosion and they try to set her up
like this very Catwoman like character
there won a DC Comics most famous or
most infamous relationship so they're
just trying to establish that chemistry
between the two of them and let you know
that they're not going to be getting
together right away or anything like
that
I think it'll pay off bigger in the end
but I do already think that they have
better chemistry those two actors then a
lot of the other couples quote-unquote
on the flash TV show or a lot of the
other DC TV shows for that matter so
even though this actress seems really
really young I am kind of happy with the
chemistry that they have together so
regardless I think it'll wind up being a
pretty interesting storyline they make a
lot of elongated
man comic book references to like when
they're back in his office she jokes
about quote-unquote the cheap stuff
talking about the jingled soda she
references jingled soda again later in
the episodes so a lot of the references
and easter eggs from their storyline are
specific to their comic book storylines
in the even reference identity crisis
which is obviously one of the most
storylines from DC Comics history but
then number 6 the new version of
mere master starts to go crazy or has
been going crazy like I said sort of
setting the stage for her eventual
descent into comic-book villainy all I
could think about when she started to
get those nervous tics was Homer Simpson
during the shining episode of The
Simpsons no beer in no TV make Homer go
crazy and then you just are chasing the
family around but then number 5 we
learn about the dirty cops inside the
police department this is obviously
culminating in what's going on with the
black hole storyline because it's all
connected in the background this is sort
of the current arc of the flash TV show
there'll be one big arc at the end of
the season after this so all the mere
master all the black hole stuff will be
culminating probably sometime around
episode 18 because that's when god speed
is coming back that's right god speed is
coming back later to this season they'll
finally pay off that storyline from the
beginning in episode 1 jo jizz has berry
go over a lot of old case work that
seems kind of fishy and he finds out
that it's connected to black hole and
ultraviolet number 4 iris in the new
mere master try the season 3 mere master
Sam Scudder fixed when they had to get
Barry out of the mirror but it
completely shatters it I did like the
take away like oh no this definitely
isn't going to work but it just served as
an intro for the new version of mere
master to realize her meta abilities I
will be interested to see how they used
this in later episodes once she goes
full comic book villain and I am curious
to see because she talks about watching
her husband for the last 5 to 6 years
slowly move on past him and obviously
he's a big villain now connected to
black hole or a big part of black hole
so it'll be fun to see if she tries to
wind up taking him down to the end by
trapping him by himself inside the
mirror dimension because she kind of
implies that being trapped in here by
herself for the last couple of years is
almost worse than death but the way her
powers work as she basically has control
over this meta mirror I'll be curious to
see how this works with other mirrors
because iris ort of touches it at the
end of the episode
and berry kind of senses her I'm
assuming it'll pry be sometime in either
next week's episode or the post credit
scene from next week's episode when they
actually figure out how to use her
abilities to take them back through the
mirror into the real world like I said
all this mirror master stuff is going on
is just the current arc of the flash
it's not going to last till the end of the
season so her as a villain or eventually
maybe turning into a villain probably
won't last more than six or seven
episodes total I'm assuming that they'll
sort of transition when Godspeed
eventually comes back to the show and
that'll be the final arc and the big
final villain of the season if it's not
god speed or reverse-flash everyone's
still holding out hope that red death is
going to wind up being one of the big
villains by the end of the season but as
part of this mirror master storyline
fake iris the near gun the Stark eyes we
also find that Nash wells is trying to
find Harrison wells from earth-2 Harry's
Journal maybe it has something to do
with him rediscovering the existence in
the multiverse that sort of this ongoing
thing like how longer the characters
going to be in the dark thinking that the
multiverse is gone and all these other
alternate versions are dead when really
most of them are probably fine they're
playing it real weird with this
mindspace earth - Harrison wells just
talking to him like nope you're lying
you're definitely lying about this she's
definitely lying about this it's an
interesting spin I've seen a lot of
interesting theories from you guys in my
feed like maybe it's Earth - Harrison
wells trying to contact him or maybe
it's reverse-flash trying to pull a fast
one on him right now the way they're
playing it is that it's mostly just a
manifestation of his guilt at what he's
done and becoming pariah him thinking
that he's responsible for the death of
all these people and responsible for
crisis even happening in the first place
number two the whole bank heist
Ralph's and Sue Dibny this is actually a
pretty good storyline this week
light years light years better than last
week's Valentine's Day episode but we
find out that she's been pulling a fast
one on him this whole time been playing
him
she was actually casing him while he was
casing her so she planted the bomb at
the beginning of the episode to mislead
him and think that John Loring which is
a big comic book Easter Egg I'll explain
in a second was after her so that she
could get some ledger but it was all
just a front so that she could steal a
big diamond from him but the big comic
book Easter egg for John Loring is
actually for the identity crisis
storyline in the death of suit didn't he
so what happened is is that Jean Loring
who was the
my wife of the atom the Ray Palmer Adam
wound up accidentally killing suit
didney then trying to cover up the crime
an identity crisis was then trying to
figure out what was behind it was it one
of the Justice League villains that
wound up killing suit didney but the big
shock was that it was Jean Loring so
they obviously made that John Loring
when when she says that he's after me
he's my former boyfriend he's just a
reference to that identity crisis
storyline but number one we find out
she was also lying about wanting to
steal the diamond because she just felt
like stealing it she's really casing
black hole and it has something to do
with that storyline so it sounds like
she's also trying to take down black
hole on her own too so if you're
confused about what's going on with Sue
Dibny's storylines she's not an evil
person she's more of an antihero they're
playing in a very Catwoman Batman like
relationship where you have a hero like
elongated man falling for an antihero
who sometimes on the wrong side of the
law but they have a very playful
relationship and she winds up helping
them sometimes but also winds up doing
bad things every once in a while I was
also kind of getting a black widow vibe
from her final a costume that she
reveals maybe a little bit black widow
maybe a little bit Catwoman catsuit just
really tight leather outfit to let you
know that she has been doing this this
whole time so obviously it's a big
change from the comic book version of
suit did knee but they want to turn her
into a more interesting character there
just wasn't a whole lot going on with
the comic book version of her character
other than being a damsel in distress so
I'm totally fine with them changing that
part of her comic book backstory but the
big idea is that next week they're
bringing back Gorilla Grodd
and so levar it's going to be a really huge
episode obviously gorilla City is now on
earth Prime in Africa so they can have
some fun playing with the idea of Earth
primes Gorilla Grodd who's a little bit
different from the other versions of
Gorilla Grodd we've seen before I'll try
to do a trailer video for that sometime
tomorrow. But everyone
click here for my Batman Teaser Trailer
and easter eggs video for
the new Robert Pattinson Batman and
click here for my brand new venom 2
carnage first look video thank you so
much for watching everyone stay awesome
this is the way!